Luke dominate here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and today we're going
caving down there
open the car hop in the car I'm starving
guys I think the campground's closed
yeah so yeah let's go do a plan B dad's
dad's got a plan B plus if we're
investing it
all right guys uh shall we do a camp out
here at the house yes yes you didn't
hang out with us yeah
they're there it doesn't hurt the glass
A little cut on the end
okay
but you don't want the butter to be
Browning
Okay match it up nicely see you look how
it's kind of Browner on one side so you
rotate it first
check them like this check up are they
they melt the inside yeah yeah that's
perfect
got the knife okay why don't you go over
there and you cut them you cut them how
you like him is this uh is this one of
the more hardcore candles we've ever
done
you guys ready to learn how to make
cobbler yeah and we got a dutch oven
there okay
okay guys this is sugar okay and we're
gonna go like this put some sugar
okay then we got some yellow cake mix I
can't try to spread it evenly across the
top it looks like a wetland okay now you
need a bottle of soda pop and I have
melon flavored Ramen a if you don't want
exotic Japanese sodas Sprite or 7Up
works well and take a thing and go
oh my face
who wants to drink the last little bit
share with your brothers
the butter like Squidward now we just
seal it up and put it in the oven
7 30 so at 8 31 we're pulling we're
gonna eat cobbler should we go build our
shelter yeah
yeah let's do it
okay grab your sleeping bag and unfluff
up your sleeping bag okay
our Lantern
okay
do you guys want to roast marshmallows
mom you want part of this action I do
I want to eat mine
[Music]
she looks like a meteor I'm probably
just going to happen all right mom is
that good
there you go
love it guys guess what time it is
cobbler time
come on everybody take a peek at it
oh what do you think of that Tom does
that look good delicious see it oh put
your plate closer I haven't had cobbler
in a long time you want more gooey stuff
yes
baby it's the best cobbler I've ever had
you like that is that good it's actually
should we go downstairs and continue our
camp out all right Mama you want to join
us
yeah get into your bed all right Jake
you're is this your bed here
is that perfect all right guys you ready
to you guys ready to watch some Star
Trek with Dad Mom all right
hot chocolate please Melissa did you
guys like Star Trek
you like that all right it's like guys
we're going to bed we'll see you in the
morning
I got up in the middle of the night used
the bathroom and I came down the stairs
and I stepped on that alligator head on
the stairs and fell down the stairs
foreign
didn't wake any of you up for breakfast
I'm making the boys a classic World War
II Soldier breakfast poo on a shingle
okay
[Music]
looks like guys
that's why it's poo on a shingle
some bread
well there we go we made ourselves a
nice little white gravy it's pretty easy
to do it's a can of spam a third a cup
of flour one to one evaporated milk to
water add some salt add some pepper if
you want to make biscuits and gravy it's
basically the same gravy that's the
that's the thickness you want
is it tasty
apparently had his goggles for some poo
on your shingle hold me your plate close
you got poo on a shingle this is a World
War II Soldier breakfast here going out
to the table
it's just like pizza
plain toast it's good well the camping
element of this video didn't quite go as
planned but we still got a whole bunch
of caving to do so we're gonna get the
boys dressed get them in the car and
we're going caving
all right guys we're here doing well hey
slim to turn down I did I lost a little
weight all right
all right guys we're here with Lester
this is actually my fourth trip with him
and we've just had a ball every time so
long pants long sleeves I'm gonna get my
coveralls on in a minute because you're
gonna get muddy today
all right here's two headlamps those are
all charged up
pulled out here but it's always the same
temperature in caves no matter how hot
or cold it gets makes the caving a great
winter
that's got some of your dad's equipment
you guys each have a headlamp a double
gather multiple lights whistles keep it
slow making sense
look at this guys we
can just take slippery yeah take it nice
and slow all right I'm right behind you
yeah
I'm doing the butt scoot boogie oh
you're right this is one isn't it nice
in here
show that pie right over there so the
sparkly stuff actually what you're often
seeing is water drops oh what's you guys
oh look at that
[Music]
it's so sparkly in here oh my goodness
oh it's wet
oh hey sure glad we slimmed down a
little bit there so now we're gonna get
to do total darkness so stay stable and
let's kill all of our lights all right
here goes the last one
oh my all right let's bring a few lights
up
oh
and let's just talk a little bit about
navigating until North
all right I'm gonna lead the next a
little bit we're gonna head this way we
get lost in the cave
[Music]
called the Commando crawl and uh when
one of you two boys like to lead this oh
you're gonna go down down and you're
gonna keep turning to your right to keep
turning which way all left
oh I remember doing this I Don't
Remember Loving it yeah
oh my gosh
I can't even see you
it's even tighter oh my gosh
oh
boy
oh I'm glad I lost that weight oh you
guys are so little
come on Tom
yeah
yeah okay Nathan I farted go for it
oh all the bats are gonna die now oh oh
I can taste it in here Tom cave gas the
Canary's dying back here
[Applause]
so I'm going to take you to another
little room over here that's kind of
cool you barely crawl in and then when
you get in the room you can actually
stand up and look around so let's head
this way you can leave
okay
you're going to crawl in here to the
right the room called the dungeon is
back in here and then when it's time to
come out you're going to crawl out that
passage right there and I will have my
red light shining so you know where to
come out make sense
all righty
ah let's take a look in here
oh look at those cool formations in
there guys
look at all the slang tights on the
ceiling that's cool
like mine on the floor
head over to Lester okay you see their
red light
you see the red light
that's a tight squeeze can you do it yes
I
said let me see how muddy you are
oh
okay so some people call this the post
office because when you're back in the
room you can look out the window we will
see your light through though
all right you may go go down belly down
oh look at that
here
oh you got it
I see you there it is let's see if you
can stick your face in
hey
that's awesome
hey well done what do you think this
Loop is here
I'm gonna head this way I will leave and
here we go
this cage is really muddy we're getting
all covered in mud but I figured the
mud's a good thing I need all the grease
I can get
no you don't
that's a nasty business can you follow
me
you want to go down that deep dark hole
all right
let's see where a big stalactite broke
off and a small soda straw is forming
call this an active ceiling this is an
inactive ceiling so follow me
oh
you're so gross
I'm scared of you falling back a minute
are you gonna go right or left here we
go I'm just touching my photos
is only a cave if it has three things
true about it so what must be true
complete darkness is one not man not
man-made must be naturally formed that's
number two big enough for a person to
get inside big enough for a human an
excellent 10 points to Gryffindor
so here you can go either way right
because sometimes you can put that map
in your hoodie pocket if you need your
hands for Stuff
[Music]
is awesome
at this point my hand now the question
is do we go to the right or to the left
left
um
it's a bigger Bridge
hello I just used that dog that's gonna
slide here we go
oh go then go let's go
big step
down to the Shelf gotcha it's your turn
and then one more step to me
you guys aren't throwing rocks up there
are you right here at the edge
six more inches big step yeah there it
is my foot in the edge and that long
step down with the left excellent
how deep underground are we so this cave
does not actually go deeper deeper
deeper it stays like here's the ground
surface it stays pretty close to the
surface maybe like 20 30 feet or
something like that yeah
we're gonna go this way next
yeah and stand up and pull
oh
there you go see how that works there
you go
isn't it raw
man down all right all right see this oh
my yeah
[Music]
we got to do that crazy all right so
I'll get yourself stabilized something
oh there's two ways until you stand up
and then when you stand up stop and wait
for your dad
all right you can follow me forever
good to see sunlight
you guys made it we survived Shelby or
Velda yeah
did you I think he got muddy Tom ah
you are disgusting but cute I'll tell
you what guys if you don't like being
out in the cold nasty weather caving's
awesome it's always the same temperature
it never rains never has wind it's a
great way to beat the winter blues and
I'll tell you what guys there's a reason
why I've been with Lester four times the
guy just does a great job he's wonderful
with kids and youth groups and it's
really really affordable check it out
there's a persimmon tree right here
the Persimmons last longer than a lot of
other fruits so they're a good early
winter fruit take your time
[Music]
there you go rob aggressively thank you
Lester good time
Guide Service it's wild guide Adventures
I'll put a link in the video description
below
[Music]
well listen I've got to go put some kids
into a bathtub hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you want to see more
videos
if you want to see more videos like this
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
so loud
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]